Hello Freak bitches.
I mean,
after we do a few episodes here will be like,
oh,
it's just,
this is the spot.
I'm sure if I companion.
Yeah.
Especially once the booze and starts again once the Busan and the weeds start
again in November.
How hard has that been for you?
Easy.
Super easy.
Click is eat.
The other day went to Mexican food and I wanted a Margarita and I went,
oh damn,
I can't have Margaret.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's literally my only craving.
People talk to you about like,
cause their initial thing wasn't quitting.
We'd write,
the initial thing was just getting Bert Kreischer to not die.
So like our idea was like,
let's see if we can get them to go sober for a month.
Yeah.
And he was like,
I can run a marathon.
I'm like,
stop.
He fucked this.
You're not going to run a marathon.
Well like,
listen,
how about instead of you running a marathon,
we just have you do 15 hot yoga classes.
And they're like,
oh,
that'd be easy when she hasn't,
haven't even done one yet.
You don't know if it's easy and now they're,
they're slogging away through like,
I think they're,
they're all at like number six or seven.
Right.
Do we have video of a bird in a hot yoga class?
No.
Video.
No,
but they've,
they take videos after him and Tom get out and they're both,
you know,
beat red and it's covered in sweat.
It's pretty,
obviously Alice just drenched.
But Burton has done amazing.
First of all,
his,
his blood pressure has dropped radically.
He was actually on high blood pressure medication.
And after this,
after stopping drinking just immediately his blood pressure dropped like
radically.
Yeah.
So like he doesn't even need blood pressure medication if he doesn't drink.
That's amazing.
It's the only thing that it's doing in men is the booze.
Right.
So,
and then,
but people would come up to me about the,
we'd see the weed wasn't in the original bet.
The original bet was just no booze,
which I thought it'd be pretty easy.
And then they're like,
all right,
we're going to go no,
no weed too.
And I was like,
no weed.
Fuck you.
Like,
I'm just doing this for Burton.
Like I don't want to stop smoking.
And then they were giving me a hard time about it.
They started this Hashtag pray for Joe Campaign Cause I was addicted to pot.
So I initially thought I'll just get off weed and not tell them until the end
and go.
It was fucking easy.
Pussies.
Yeah.
But then our,
he was making such a big deal out of it.
I would say actually dude,
I'm not smoking pot either just to let the cat out of the bag.
Thompson I already knew.
But um,
people come up to you like,
like you're not eating for a month like you.
Okay.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
How do you feel you off heroin for good,
you know,
but it's such a part of it for you isn't it?
Never seemed like an addiction.
Drugs too.
For my vision of you doing drugs is it's always mind expanding and it's always
just to relax.
It's never like an addiction.
It never felt like you needed to.
I definitely don't need it obviously,
because that's a great sets too,
which has been very interesting because I usually like to go on stay tie.
I haven't done that at all though.
No,
no pot for 17 days.
Is that what today is?
What's today?
The 17th so no pot for 17 days.
Where do you miss it the most before going on?
No,
I haven't missed it.
Wow.
It's been weird.
You know?
I was like,
maybe there's going to be a moment where like,
wow,
I'd like to have some weak.
I'm a little nervous about smoking again.
Yeah.
Because I know I'm going to get so high that I'm so paranoid and all these
demons are going to come creeping up into my consciousness again.
Paranoid.
Yeah.
Psychic demons.
It is going to come float and by,
it's like that first orgasm after you get your prostate removed.
Yeah,
man.
For Real.
You know,
like once,
once you're back,
you know,
it's just,
just seems like,
um,
it seems like it's going to hit your way,
way,
way harder,
right?
That's what everybody says.
Yeah.
You take a month off and then he'd get back on the pot.
Then you know why everybody freaks out when you get them high.
You know,
because we're so used to getting high that will we get high.
It's no big deal.
Yeah.
But when people don't get high and they're like,
oh,
I'll smoke a little weed with you,
but they haven't smoked pot.
Maybe like six months or something like that.
Yeah.
Those people are fucked.
Right?
They're in a bad place.
Yeah.
I got a nice easy rhythm gone.
I got the little vape pen and I'm seeing what?
I'm a mom on the road,
you know,
Thursday,
Friday night,
couple hits.
That's pretty much it.
And you never do it before shows,
right?
Never.
Never,
ever.
And you took a long time.
Like when,
when I first met you,
we back in the day,
um,
when we first started out,
you would just quit boots,
right?
Like just quit.
Yeah.
And you weren't doing nothing.
No Pot,
no booze,
no nothing.
Like,
what was it that made you realize I could smoke little,
it was new year's eve
of
I turned 49,
2004.
Whoa.
So I had not smoked pot for 14 years or drank or anything.
And then I'm standing outside of the Improv in San Francisco and I'm with,
I won't mention the manager's name,
but a manager who smokes a lot of pot that we all know and love.
And uh,
the entire cast of the marijuana logs has Doug Benson,
Tony,
uh,
can mean and,
um,
Brian Poe sane and they're all there.
It's just like a weird thing where,
you know,
I don't know if you've ever done New Year's eve in San Francisco,
but there's like three different venues at all,
do comedy,
you know,
there's Cobbs is the punchline and then there's a big theater that the Palai the
palace of fine arts or whatever.
And then there's an after party at the punchline and it's the greatest after
party because usually you go on the road and after your show you're just kind of
alone.
Maybe you got to your opener or whatever and you hang out.
But this is always like,
you know,
every comic in San Francisco comes together and I'm standing out front end and
they're standing there with a joint.
They hand it to me and I just,
I felt like this is the moment I'm supposed to smoke pot again.
And I did.
And uh,
and then the weirdest fucking thing happened is,
um,
I went down to help Molly,
you know,
she had a,
um,
the van coming from the palace and she had a box of booze that had been the
backstage bar and she's a bottle of vodka and she's walking towards the steps
and his group,
and we were talking about San Francisco homeless people before group of like,
you know,
they're like 21 and they're like,
Streeter.
Chin's yeah.
They're like,
you know,
it's almost like,
yeah,
the warrior come out.
It's like that type of person.
And they grabbed the bottle of booze out of Molly's hand and I'm standing there
with Todd Barry,
Paul f Tompkins,
and like,
I think Greg Proops,
it's like two guys in suits.
And so they grabbed this bottle for Molly and she chases after them.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you doing this that your booze?
It's the clubs,
booze.
And she runs right in the middle of them and they,
uh,
she grabs a bottle and she's fighting with this woman over it and these guys are
surrounding her and I run in and I grab her and start pulling her out.
But at the same time,
guys,
a fist cocked waiting to take a shot at me and I'm yelling to these guys,
hey,
how about a little help here and nothing.
And so,
uh,
I kind of pull her out of there and we have run away.
And then as we're walking up the stairs,
they throw a blockbuster and mad oh,
Jesus.
And it landed right near us and it blew out.
O and m there was less.
People don't know what that means is a firecracker.
Oh,
like a super bits and eighth of a stick of dynamite isn't really that.
That's what an mat is.
Jesus Christ.
I didn't know.
Is that powerful?
Yeah.
I mean,
you feel it in your chest.
And a blew out Molly's hearing for like a year and,
uh,
people were crying.
It was like really traumatic and I'm high.
I'm like,
this is the fucking war.
After 14 years,
I was just like,
fuck,
this is nuts.
I was walking the girl back to the hotel because she was sobbing.
I wasn't tig.
It was a,
it was a lesbian comedian who had a girlfriend weather and uh,
yeah.
It was fucking crazy.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Okay.